joining us now with reaction fox news
contributors joe koncha charlie hurt and
arizona congressman andy biggs uh
congressman i'll start with you um the
idea that the department of justice is
tipping off uh one of the biggest social
media platforms on the planet facebook
and erroneously labeling it as russian
disinformation so they had the
justification to hey we're gonna
suppress this how is that not just
another example of political bias at the
department of justice and what in the
world can you do about it as a member of
the judiciary committee there in the
house
well it's this thanks to high heavens
jason and it is a great example of the
political bias that we've seen and
you've been discussing
tonight but i will tell you this
zuckerberg doesn't have clean hands
because he distributed over 400 million
dollars to try to influence the election
so he was really a susceptible target to
fbi disinformation and that's what it
was here about this election and so what
the judiciary committee is going to have
to do and the oversight committee as
well we're going to have to get in and
get the fbi and we're going to have to
bring this thing to gr uh ground we're
gonna have to uh find out who
actually approved this this
disinformation campaign uh to facebook
and twitter and and the big big tech
behemoths that are going to influence
the election that's critical jason and i
think we can do it uh with jim jordan i
hope will be the
the chairman there and jamie comer and
oversight and and we're ready to do it
i've actually been talking with the the
chairman of oversight today about some
of these issues so
we're ready to go and i told him i said
we need to get we need to get our
preservation letters going we need to
make sure we're ready to go on day one
to bring that fbi in because christopher
wray just a couple of months ago said
well look you know
if if that happened that'd be
problematic it's not problematic yeah it
is potentially criminal in nature
well look director ray was hired to
clean up the fbi but all you have to do
is read through the 1 000 pages for the
inspector general and you'll find
more than a dozen instances where the
fbi uh used its political influence
to affect elections joe joe who else
besides clinton and biden get this kind
of heads up and this sort of political
help from what is supposed to be the
impartial department of justice
well that's the big question jc right
and it's beyond alarming that here you
have the u.s government in the form of
the fbi telling a very private and quite
large communications platform
we're talking billions of members
what news should and should not be
shared on their platforms and in
facebook they didn't outright censor the
hunter biden story sure like twitter did
but they sure did suppress it per
zuckerberg zuckerberg's own admission
and what strikes me most about this clip
was how nonchalant zuckerberg was in
sharing this information with joe rogan
like he was talking about his trip to
you know bed bath and beyond as if the
fbi coming to him to warn him about a
specific story obviously negative to the
democratic nominee it's all perfectly
normal and by the way jason here's what
i want to know did the fbi go to
zuckerberg about other stories during
that campaign campaign season for
instance did they advise him speaking of
russia to be highly highly skeptical
about the now debunked story that the
russians had bounties on u.s troops and
trump ignored it because that was a huge
story in 2020 biden even broached it
during the debates as a gotcha it turns
out it was completely false but it
appears the fbi had no issue with that
story being amplified on facebook and on
twitter and and the big question also
now is top brass at the fbi and we're
certainly not talking about the boots on
the ground the people that do the hard
work but the top people are they taking
sides politically against a political
party that's the question that we have
and zuckerberg and chris wray
trump appointed fbi director they need
to be re-summoned to capitol hill to
explain all of this when republicans
take back control of congress it is
vital that we need to start
you know trusting our institutions again
jason
yeah and that that is the heart of the
issue lady justice is supposed to have
that blindfold but i got to tell you
clinton's and and bidens get a special
kind of treatment and then when you have
two sitting united states senators uh uh
charlie asking for information and those
documents are being slow walked
i mean what is the public to do if how
are you going to gain trust back in the
system if our elected representatives
and senators cannot get to the heart of
this information
well i honestly i hate to say it jason
but i think that the only way that the
fbi
and the doj reclaim credibility is to
clean house and and i don't think the
doj is capable of cleaning house
themselves i think it has to be done by
congress that's the or the executive
branch in two years that's the only way
you
root out this level of rot you know
let's not forget the fbi did everything
they could to to rig the 2016 election
they failed but that you know they
refused to to prosecute hillary clinton
for what was clearly crimes they admit
were crimes they spied on donald trump
uh a candidate uh for president at the
height of a presidential campaign um and
it's like we're starting to realize now
2020
they were just hell bent to do what they
failed to do in 2016. it's almost like
they were as angry as mark zuckerberg
was that his platform got used by an
army of trump supporters uh to spread
the message and the and the issues and
the campaign that donald trump was
running on uh and that they were just
hell bent on uh using their power
there's extraordinary power in order to
destroy donald trump and prop up joe
biden and then of course we now have the
situation where you have the fbi
literally
going after republicans in the united
states senate and preventing them from
doing their jobs these are
massive constitutional issues and if
they don't get addressed we are screwed
as a country
well here's why i'm so skeptical and and
truly worried kevin kleinsmith worked at
the fbi altered documents yeah guess
what he pled guilty to that yep and just
a few months later the bar reinstated
him to full service hiki is a practicing
attorney no problem keep on hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else